Cisco, what happened to everybody?
That's something you're gonna need to see for yourself
You're from before she dies aren't you?
2024, I made it
Tell me who Savitar is, we'll stop him before he even tries
you're gonna be so surprised when you find
out you're in for a world of pain
The Flash all-new episodes return Tuesday
April 25th August CW
Hey everybody what's up new Flash
footage future Barry vs. Barry so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get everything I do Marvel
and DC videos every week leave me all
your requests for bonus videos during
the flash break in the comments below
the more requests you guys leave me the
better our discussions tend to be
But let's just dive right in at the future
flash costumes so this is the thing
everybody was freaking out about last
night that and killer frost so we'll
talk about her too but it looks a little
more like the new 52 version with the
lightning that sort of goes all over his
body now obviously in the comics that's
all Speed Force Lightning that goes
around him so they're just doing it
practically here in the belt is extra
big I know a lot of people aren't big
fans of the belt but the costume just
made to look more hardcore in the tone
of this very hardcore post-apocalyptic
wasteland after Iris's death and I know
like people were wondering who this hand
is here it's all scarred and burned
presumably that's not iris West because
they keep talking about her being dead I
think people just saw this hand it
looked African Americans are like well
it can't be Wally because while he's in
a wheelchair so who is this person here
but the other big thing that you may
have noticed is that it looks like he's
traveled to the date on that future
newspaper 2024 that's like the date that
he travels to in the future what a
coincidence that the day that the flash
is coming back April 25th
remember it's on break for about 4 weeks
is the same day on the future newspaper
so it's almost like we're traveling to
this future crisis point where he
disappears what this is implying is that
Savitar kills Iris and that sort of
fractures the team everybody goes their
separate ways Wally is injured in the
attack so likes Savitar breaks his back
he can't walk anymore or run remember
that's the only thing that he loves and
even though Julian still seems like
he's with Cisco here like he still seems
like he's on the team you see Killer
Frost who is just as bad as ever and
Mirror Master is back it looks like he
has run of the town now because Captain
Cold is on Legends of Tomorrow normally
it would be Captain Cold and Heat Wave
because we got to talk about the
alternate timeline on legends so I might
save that for my arrow video because
there are so many big things that
happened in the last like two or three
days so you guys can let me know in the
comments like how you want me to address
the legends of tomorrow stuff 100% not a
fan of the look of emo Barry here
hopefully they burned this timeline
alive and because it's darkest
timeline of course they want to change
things you don't think that they're
going to go into season 4 with things
being this depressing so you got Barry
going to the future you have future
Barry that's pissed at Barry from the
past for not succeeding in saving iris
like Barry hates himself in this future
timeline more than anything so I'm
expecting them to come to blows just a
little bit how couldn't you save her
like him just going crazy on him but
there's the other person that they cast
for the future timeline so I don't know
if she's going to show up during this
episode or if she'll be from further in
the future because Abra Kadabra is from
the 64th century so he knew about all
these things that had happened over the
Flash's lifetime but Barry's only gone
forward and handful of years the funny
thing about this too is it almost makes
it seem like this is the end of season
10 of the flash I don't know if the
flash is actually going to last that
long but it would be hardcore if they
ended on a bummer note like this people
would be pissed but it's all about
finding Savitar's identity and Killer
Frost teases him you'll be so surprised
when you find out like it's somebody
that you would never expect and we don't
see HR anywhere in any of the trailers
so there's a big question about what
happens to him too because he was there
the night of Savitar's attack, Savitar
taunted him by saying that he survives
his wrath so unless there's some big
twist he should appear in the episode
but because Tom Cavanagh directed it
maybe that's an excuse for him not being
in it like maybe something happened to
him after Savitar's attack and that's why
he's not on the team enabling Tom
Cavanagh to have the extra time to
direct the episode because usually when
you direct an episode you don't have as
much time to star in it in a big way
Savitar's identity though I know a lot
of you have started to say that you're
getting really tired with the way
they're stringing this out and it
doesn't matter as much that's actually
kind of the thing they're going for it's
meant to be in MacGuffin but the whole
idea is that Barry's fear in the actions
that he takes because of that lead to
the rise of sabotage for the title of
the episode once and future flash is
actually pretty loaded it's a big
Reverse Flash Mark Waid story that sort
of tells his version of the origin story
Geoff Johns has his own version of the
Eobard Thawne origin story it's a
little bit different from Mark Waid but
we'll see if there are any Easter eggs
from that when we get to the actual
episode sometimes they just use the
titles of famous comic books without
using the storylines so we'll see but
it's all about the
reverse-flash masquerading as Barry
Allen and then Wally West finding out
kicking his ass sending him back to the
future
so the comic book titled the once and
future flash refers to the once flash
Barry Allen because he's dead when the
comic book is taking place in future
flash is the reverse flash so you have
the future flash masquerading as the
once flash if that sounds kind of
confusing but in the context of this
episode you have the once flash - Barry
Allen from the past talking to the
future flash the future Barry Allen so
it's the once and future flash if you're
a big lit geek Mark Waid is the one that
came up with that title the once and
future flash it's a reference to the
once and future king basically a story
about the rise and fall of King Arthur
so King Arthur in this sense is Barry
Allen so it's a very tragic tale so it's
kind of a bummer
hopefully the flash will get back on
track because it does get fatiguing when
it gets relentlessly dark like this like
Oh someone's going to die this is such a
bummer so what I think they'll do is
they'll try to find a way to resolve
this avatar plot pay that off in a
rewarding way and sort of usher things
in in an exciting way to season four so
we'll see if they can pull it off but
what's going to happen is is there'll be
some more promos in the next couple
weeks so they'll be dropping new footage
so what I'll do is I'll be posting bonus
videos every week just leave me all your
requests for what you guys want to talk
about the more requests you leave me the
better our discussions are we'll say
congratulations to Dan demand you're the
latest flash ring giveaway winner please
private message be on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details the giveaways will just keep
going during the break so no worries
I'll announce the winner the next time I
post a flash video so what's going to
happen next is is people are freaking
out about spider-man homecoming so I'll
post a video explaining what's going on
with that when you wait for that you can
click here for all the flash Easter eggs
from last night and you can click here
for all the Justice League that I posted
this week thank you so much for watching
let's high five I'll see you guys in the
next video